imagine that your child you are tender
souls and environment is a word that
nobody understand my job is to train the
next explorers of grandmother earth to
be teacher to be environmental
instructors that's why I wanted to
create a special place to have fun and
rare so imagine the open Tundra is more
like a theme park when you can find all
the methodologies and all the tools that
you need to be an environmentalist how
can a big we stay inside a litter seat
when you listen about global warming who
can understand what that means
sounds difficult
in our classroom there are no boards the
chairs and no tables so my job is to
create games with children and
understand how can we predict nation
environment when a Chinese has to be a
[ __ ] hero of we're on mother earth he
spent all the weekends of one you
learning about water biodiversity
planting and then he get accreditation
like an environmental instructor because
I feel that children are the best
teachers in the world I feel that I'm
not working I feel that I am just doing
why I really love
but I really want to do it their support
for that children who are going to be
the future but they need to take action
now let's say life did exist on the
surface of Mars would it be able to
withstand the bacteria the viruses all
of the bad things that we have on earth
without having the protection because
it's never seen it before